physicists mean by free will like in
conway's free will theorem and so on
it's kind of distorted from what the
term is normally meant in the
larger in the parlance of philosophers
more generally
and anyway as i say i think it's
motivated reasoning
how about we define free will or you
define free will and then tell the
audience what your inference theorems
have to say about free will you'll have
to define free will and also define what
your inference theorem is and then what
the inference theorem has to say about
free will okay so um
first a warning there is a
unfortunate tendency it should have a um
particular name as one of the rhetorical
fallacies it's you know the ad hominem
policy that this fallacy the that
fallacy
for people to take a term that's in very
common use
and is very controversial because of all
these reasons
they want to establish that it's true
so they redefine it in a certain way
that they can establish that true
that redefinition
all of the original reasons that are so
controversial
they are now defined out
and what you're left with is actually a
very different kind of a concept
and they now then herald it and say oh
look
i've just proved such and such where
what they've really done is redefined it
in such a way that they could prove it
but all the reason people were
interested in the first place is now out
of their new definition so it's a bait
and switch
the fallacy is called martin bailey i
believe
martin bailey okay um how's that spelled
m-o-t-t-e
and then bailey's as the drink i believe
essentially you mean so you take some
fact and then you're straw manning it
and you use the straw man to disprove
the larger one
yeah or to prove it as the case might be
martin bailey that's nice i've got to
look that up later so continue
so yes so um for example um okay so
certainly if you're familiar with the
concept
um the notion of god has been treated
that way
um you know many people say oh einstein
really believe in god because you know
he said the laws of nature and so the
rules of nature is god um
but of course the reason that
god is considered to be a controversial
topic is because it's a benefimorphized
it's this dude in the sky with a big
beard who's deciding who's going to win
the football game sunday night
um and
that's the one that's controversial and
so on so forth and einstein wasn't
saying anything about in favor of that
particular one
um so it's a little bit of a modern
balance um
and frankly
um i think that he has done some great
work and he's a
good friend and a great guy but i think
that
dan dennett was recently um involved in
this with um free will
he hum wrote a book and which he tries
to now claim i've proven free will and
in essence he's defined a way it's
aspects that made it controversial in
the first place
so
what do i mean by free will um there's a
there's one aspect to it which is that
which would be that of the people who
write dictionaries what does it mean in
common discourse
and what i think free will means and
common discourse has something to do
with
a means by which
it is possible to
abrogate the laws of deterministic
science
in such a way that a human's cognitions
are not
subject to those laws
so that what is going on in your head
right now is not
some very complicated too complicated to
calculate but nonetheless
um uh inviable
function
of what it was you were thinking 10
seconds ago together with the stimuli
sensory stimuli from your environment
but somehow there's something else
that is not subject to any laws of
science in some sense it's not even
subject to sarcastic laws it's just
amorphous and ill-defined and
in that and so certainly all of us
have a
subjective experience of such a
thing um but the proponents of free will
in this country in this um sense which
is controversial would say that no
that's actually an objective truth
um i don't see that there's any room for
that to be quite honest um
so in that sense no i don't
if that's what
if we do adopt that kind of a definition
which i think isn't according with the
way it's used in common parlance
no i don't see it there's any room for
such a thing you can
you can maybe kind of get close and
scott aronson again he's involved
engaged in a martin baileys
in this particular paper of his
but he and even more worse martin
bailey's as seth lloyd they try to make
the case that turing machine notions of
computability
provide a way out in that they say that
yes it might be
the various flavors of the argument but
one version of it is
yes the
present state of your mind is a
deterministic function of what it was
and so on but it's an uncomputable
function
in some technical senses
yeah stephen wolfram says something
similar where he uses his term
computational irreducibility and says
well yes there are outcomes that are
computationally irreducible and that's
where free will may live but ultimately
you don't have control over the laws
it's still a deterministic step-by-step
algorithmic process yeah um and in a
certain sense it's kind of interesting
because
one might ask in terms of the laws of
science or physics or how the universe
actually evolves
is there any room for anything besides
deterministic or stochastic evolution
i can write down the definition
you can go look it up in math textbooks
whereas stochastic processes
and you can look up in math textbooks
what a deterministic convertible process
is
i mean you can actually formulate the
one that is a special case of the other
is there any way you can even in theory
imagine
science that would not be either random
or deterministic is anything else it
could possibly be
and there are notions in the original
motivation for
um komogorov
in terms of his work in komodo
complexity
and many other people who are wondering
about intrinsic randomness
what does um complexity mean what does
random really mean
they came up with definitions which
is something that is random
but is not random but it has no
probability distributions
so it's interesting to think about what
whether that might provide any kind of a
whether that's a difference without
significance or whether there is a
significance to that possibility
that physical systems might in essence
violate the physical church touring
thesis
and have
this kind of an uncomputable character
to them which is not random and it's not
deterministic but it's something
different and that whether that has any
kinds of consequences even if it's true
so that's interesting in almost like a
philosoph philosophy of science kind of
a way
um but it really is i would say
irredeemably far from what people mean
by free will to really say that it's
relevant to the discussions that
people have about what free will is i
think for them
for the vast majority of what
philosophers have meant by by it for
millennia
it's no it's certainly nothing to do
with komodo complexity and turing
machines and so on and so forth
it's simply the notion of their this
supernatural in the literal sense of
above nature above the laws of nature
which is inherent in me
and my soul and i cannot even define it
because it is something that's
non-definable
and that allows for
superseding of the laws of physics when
it comes to my own brain
that's what is sometimes meant
um i think that's most
fully what is
meant by people who are talking about
free will have been talking about
historically
and i almost view it as
a non-starter
okay so to make a summary for the
audience who just wants a clear answer
do we have free will or not
in that sense i don't think it's even
meaningful to say that we do
um i don't see that you can
if you you almost by that definition one
is almost defining free will to be
something that's undefinable
and it are and is supernatural
and i
[Music]
can't even almost react to that as if
it's not definable i can't say anything
and if it's not
and i don't see there is a room for any
supernatural things in
all notions of reality
um circling back to a previous theme one
of the things i find most beautiful
about
the our inconsequentiality
is that the whole notion of
consciousness
it's a post hoc fable that we cook up to
try to give us the illusion that we're
in control of our own brains there's all
these fascinating
phenomena going about like ben ben lee
bit and so on
demonstrating that it's at least um
logically consistent in fact seems to be
the case
that um all the things that we think
we're in control of we're we're not in
control in any meaningful sense of any
of them we're making enough stories
after the fact corpus callosum
severed people going you know that whole
literature
it's fascinating that when you ask one
half of a brain why the other half is
doing what it is
that that they cannot know they can
factor physically impossible but they
think that they do
with complete conviction the obvious
next step is how can i believe
what reason do i have for believing that
my conviction
that i'm in control is any more
legitimate than that of the hemisphere
that's in this convict
that it's in control
so let me steel man the opponent so with
regard to the supernatural
most
religious people would say that there is
no supernatural let's forget about most
religious people there is the view that
there is no supernatural even in the
religious domain
that god operates by natural law in fact
god is natural law and then we may say
well god is supposed to be a man in the
sky etc however that wasn't the case up
until about 200 or 300 years ago at
least it wasn't the majority case and
mysticism christian mysticism in
particular was extremely rampant where
you can't define god attempts to do so
are actually
considered to be sinful because any
instantiation of god is going to not
incorporate what god truly is so god's
left somewhat ill-defined that we can
communicate with it maybe not in a
propositional sense like we write down
words maybe in a felt sense regardless
there's no supernatural so whatever
exists whether they're ghosts or psychic
phenomena that's a natural phenomenon it
just isn't incorporating the natural
sciences currently so there's no above
nature and i agree that this is what
free will should be defined as there's
somehow
us interacting with nature that is
different than just the physical laws we
know it so it's a metaphysical statement
when we think that we have free will and
then you were saying yeah it would have
to be supernatural because it's above
the laws of physics well
remus mullion i'm sure you've heard of
remus million the mathematician he had
many writings on free will and he would
say
what defines you what's the difference
between you and natural law you're a
product of natural on we tend to think
of free will as not existing because the
outside world is more powerful than us
and somehow despite our will
it just overcomes us however that would
mean that there's a distinction between
you and natural law well
that's illusory so in some sense you are
natural law so in some sense well
but so leave it there so what is the
meaning of free will is it just a
psychological phenomenon that people
have this sense of agency yeah sure
that's definitely true that half of a
hemisphere thinks it's in control of the
other one
and yeah there's all kinds of
is there a psychological phenomenon just
like people can get depressed just like
people can become obsessive-compulsive
just like much more commonly everybody
your yours truly as well
feels has this feeling
that you're in control yes and it's
interesting maybe to look at some of the
neurobiology behind some of that
but if that's what the statement is
then yeah it's definitely true just go
do a survey do people feel this way yeah
they would do